bonsoir Alexandra
bonsoir Patrice alors si le fil c'est
l'histoire il faut que que les gens
comprennent vraiment l'histoire que
raconte depuis le d le D le jour
Monsieur Poutine qui dit si j'ai dû être
agressif c'est parce que l'Ouest ça
paraît petit à petit de l'Ukraine qui
dans le fond et mon jardin
oui en fait si vous m'aviez demandé
Patrice qu'est-ce qu'il y avait de
nouveau dans ce discours je vous aurais
dit la réponse courte rien et c'est
toujours le même mélange qu'utilise
Vladimir Poutine depuis juste avant
cette guerre et même bien avant et c'est
un mélange de fait alternatif de réalité
alternative de menaces et de promesses
aux Russes surtout alors des faits
alternatives comme vous avez dit c'est
l'Occident qui a déclenché cette guerre
la Russie ne fait que se défendre parce
qu'on a voulu humilier la Russie la
Russie est menacée par un oxydant
corrompu un Occident pervers ou la
pédophilie est devenue
est devenu la norme je veux dire on
aurait on aurait tout vu et qui veut
dire aux enfants
pardon il a dit ça aujourd'hui ce que
vous venez de dire il a littéralement
dit ça que l'Occident était corrompu
était un royaume des pédophiles que il a
même cité presque certain là
ah oui oui Satan me revient de plus en
plus souvent dans ses discours mais
c'est toujours la même rengaine comme
vous avez dit donc ce sont des élites
occidentales surtout américaines c'est
elle qui gère le régime nazi de Kiev est
une marionnette entre les mains de ses
élites et c'est ses élites là qui ont
déclenché cette guerre et qui continuent
à amener cette guerre et cette guerre
aujourd'hui ça c'est peut-être un petit
peu différent cette guerre aujourd'hui
parce que c'est commentateurs l'ont déjà
dit plusieurs fois à la télévision mais
lui il l'a pas dit aussi souvent
cette guerre est aujourd'hui est une
guerre contre l'Occident contre l'OTAN
l'Ukraine n'a plus grand chose à savoir
là-dedans et évidemment aussi des
menaces alors les menaces là menacent
principal aujourd'hui qui en fait c'est
déjà acté apparemment il va se retirer
de star du traité START 3 qui limitait
le nombre de Gilles nucléaires aux
États-Unis comme en Russie depuis 2010
et le nombre de missiles balistiques qui
devaient transport présenter ses ogives
donc on se retire pourquoi parce que le
continuez plus parce que le temps c'est
pas seulement les Américains il y a
d'autres puissances nucléaires et ça ne
rentre pas dans le calcul donc on se
retire mais aussi parce qu'on veut pas
que les inspecteurs américains viennent
inspecter des installations nucléaires
chez nous parce que ces installations là
pourraient devenir des cibles pour les
armes que maintenant les États-Unis et
le temps fournit de façon régulière à
l'Ukraine donc voilà on se retire de 3
et quand je disais la réalité
alternative il a beaucoup parlé de
l'économie la moitié de son discours
c'était pour dire que l'économie russe
va très bien que malgré les sanctions le
chômage n'a jamais été aussi bas le
déficit est beaucoup moins grand qu'on a
qu'on ne l'avait prédit tout va bien le
rouble ne sait pas écroulé alors nous
allons continuer à investir à développer
notre économie et les promesses à partir
de cette situation économique on va
créer un fond spécial pour venir en aide
aux familles des soldats morts en France
ou des soldats blessés on va donner des
appartements gratuits à des ingénieurs
qui vont s'engager dans le complexe
militarro industriel parce que on se
prépare à une guerre de longue durée
aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra bon
alors est-ce que comment on peut savoir
dans quelle mesure
cette histoire qu'il raconte depuis vous
le dites depuis très longtemps la cette
histoire qu'il raconte que l'Occident
comme corrompu l'Ukraine et que
dans quelle mesure les Russes le croient
dans quel c'est sûr que les sondages
c'est difficile à établir mais est-ce
que son pouvoir Alexandra vacille ou ne
vacille pas
je vous dirais qu'il n'a pas l'air à
vaciller et les Russes ceux qui sont
restés du moins parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui sont partis et ceux qui
sont restés y croient à ce qu'il dit ou
font semblant de le croire ou détournent
le regard mais s'ils détournent le
regard c'est qu'il est pas très menacé
et en fait aujourd'hui il a c'était une
réaffirmation de son pouvoir
à l'adresse de son propre peuple et de
ses propres élites fallait voir ces gens
qui étaient là dans la salle qui ont
applaudis j'ai calculé 53 fois et quatre
fois ils se sont levés debout et pour
l'applaudir mais ils étaient à 30 mètres
il était à 30 mètres de en avant et vous
avez vu Biden vous avez mentionné byden
tout à l'heure qui s'est présenté à
Varsovie qui a fini son discours avec
des photos hop avec des enfants en
polonais Ukrainiens qui étaient là dans
dans l'assistance la poutine il est à 30
mètres de ses propres élites qu'il doit
garder à distance parce que il en
quelque part mais il a réaffirmé son
pouvoir de façon très claire il n'avait
pas l'air malade il avait l'air bon il
était un peu pâlant et il était pas dans
ses meilleurs jours il utilisait des
expressions vraiment savoureuses il y a
quand même un langage assez savoureux
mais peut-être moins que d'habitude mais
il faut pas oublier qu'il se prépare
aussi aux élections présidentielles
l'année prochaine en 2024 c'est
l'élection présidentielle bon c'est
toujours prévisible maintenant en Russie
mais quand même il faut il faut qu'il
réaffirme son pouvoir parce que au front
ça ne va pas si ça au front les il
manque de il va manquer de munitions il
va manquer le matériel sophistiqué il va
manquer de char là la clé bon la Chine
le représentant de la Chine est à Moscou
aujourd'hui est-ce que la Chine vont
donner des armes ou pas à l'Ukraine on
attend beaucoup cette décision là qui
sera fondamentale pour la suite des
choses mais ça va pas bien sur le front
là donc que à force de mal aller cette
guerre-là peut quand même gruger son
pouvoir est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui
se prépare derrière là
écoutez pour l'instant il y a des noms
qui circulent
pétrochent enfin il y a plusieurs noms
qui circulent mais on ne sait rien c'est
un pouvoir qui est extrêmement opaque
comme vous le savez il y a pas de
d'opposition comme on la connaît chez
nous comment on la connaît en Occident
donc on sait pas vraiment et c'est sûr
que Vladimir Poutine et il est dans une
fuite en avant il peut pas reculer et
parce qu'il sait que s'il recule il y
aura un tribunal international il va
être arrêté vous savez il a hantise de
Vladimir Poutine c'est
Kadhafi qui a été attrapé et
violet traîné dans la rue et cette chose
là le honte il l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises à des gens qui étaient proches
de lui et enfin c'est ce qui a filtré et
c'est ce sont des images qu'il a et il
sait que il risque de finir comme ça
s'il ne mène pas cette guerre jusqu'à la
victoire et vous avez entendu Biden
aujourd'hui on ne laissera pas l'Ukraine
cette guerre ce n'est pas encourageant
pour la suite des choses parce qu'on est
devant devant un blocage total Alexandra
merci on va se reparler de ça parce que
je savais que vous alliez écouter ça
avec beaucoup d'intérêt ce discours
Alexandra ce matin on a pensé à vous on
se on se revoit on se rappelle merci
beaucoup
au plaisir Patrice à la prochaine à la
prochaine